im rheinland pfälzischen st goarshausen
ist die freiwillige feuerwehr in diesem
völlig heruntergekommenen gerätehaus
untergebracht bei jedem einsatz bricht
das große chaos aus weil es für die
ganze mannschaft nur diesen kleinen
umkleideraum gibt seit jahrzehnten wird
den ehrenamtlichen feuerwehrleuten eine
neue wache versprochen aber nichts
passiert so unter aller sau sagt mir was
da läuft momentan 40 halt so als würde
man sich wertgeschätzt werden definitiv
und als wäre das ganze nicht werden
macht das ja auch in seiner freizeit und
ehrenamtlich von die zustände
katastrophal
die garagen sind viel zu klein für die
fahrzeuge
in dem altbau blüht überall der schimmel
dabei sollte es eigentlich zwei ecken
weiter schon längst ungefähr so aussehen
denn auf diesem grundstück plant die
verbandsgemeinde seit inzwischen acht
jahren eine neue feuerwache
tatsächlich steht hier immer noch ein
uraltes industriegebäude der grund weil
bereits in der planung die kosten
explodiert sind hat sich der
landesrechnungshof rheinland pfalz
eingeschaltet das ergebnis der prüfung
ist vernichtend schon der kaufvertrag
sei gesetzeswidrig weil das grundstück
viel zu teuer erworben wurde
obendrein seien allein an abriss und
sanierungskosten über zwei millionen
euro nötig der kaufvertrag ist aus
unserer sicht wichtig ferner ist das
gelände unwirtschaftlich und vor allen
dingen für die zwecke der feuerwehr
unzweckmäßig seit acht jahren verfolgte
bürgermeister also einen plan der viel
zu teuer und obendrein auch noch
rechtswidrig ist sehe ich persönlich
nicht so beide beide hinweise lassen
sich durchaus wieder legen und das sind
wir gerade dabei das zu tun und wollen
dann im gespräch auch erreichen dass
diese bedenken zurück genommen werden
damit damit wir eine möglichkeit
überhaupt haben ein
auszubauen das bedeutet hier passiert
jetzt erst mal gar nichts
ausbaden müssen den stillstand die
feuerwehrleute die sind total frustriert
das problem ist wir sitzen zwischen den
stühlen und werden von allen seiten im
regen stehen gelassen
hier muss jetzt was passieren wir werden
eben nicht so richtig wertgeschätzt wir
stecken da unsere zeit investieren
unsere zeit rein und kriegen halt nicht
mal neues gerätehaus auf der suche nach
einem alternativen standort geht in
sankt goarshausen alles von vorne los es
wird wohl noch jahre dauern bis die
frauen und männer der freiwilligen
feuerwehr endlich eine vernünftige
feuerwache haben